hey guys welcome back to brandy we were
back on monster on a world again today
this was just recently released on the
Monster Hunter subreddit credit to the
number 3000 on reddit for posting this
but basically this is from a leak a
rumor from e3 and it's about something
from fortune that someone put on the
website about like I said the e3
conference for Monster Hunter world so
let's talk about that but really quick
like always liked if you can do enjoy
discography new I cover the solo guides
for every single monster a monster
haunted world mostly higher up one
specifically I also come for the weekly
event quest to let you know which ones
to do as well as news tips and guides
and all that type of stuff for monster
on our world so let's get started I
would just like to clarify first though
that this may be 100% false this may be
100% truth I haven't there is no way of
telling what is true and what is not
we're just going to hopefully speculate
and then maybe give our thoughts up
maybe this could happen or maybe this
isn't so let's first look at this photo
and see what it is just for copyright
reasons I will not show the image on
screen just in case I don't know how cop
how Capcom does their type of copyright
stuff but I don't want to take any risk
so I will leave it in the link below you
can check it and then you can watch the
video with me as we look around and see
what it says on the for champ post but
first it says anyway these are all the
details I know during the Sony
conference the monster underworld
director will arrive on stage say thanks
to the fans for the huge success of
Monster owner world the Robie no monster
on our world ultimate quick announcement
of the summer festival which will start
on June 22nd and featuring the stuff
already seen plus the oh Roshi Kieran
temperate included just like Luna and
then just like Cove a latarian or a
Letran will be introduced during the
last days of the festival and mid-july
this is going to be a reoccurring
limited time event quest so just like
this says this new monster ala Triana
once again I have no clue how this is
going to be pronounced but it's similar
to cool Toth bulb will be coming back
and maybe in the sense that it could be
a siege mode maybe it's just a new
monster with a limited time event quest
stuff like that but will come back just
like wolf to Roth has in the past after
that they will show a trailer for the
new map which will be shown a Tundra
like map on the coast with a pine forest
in the north of the new world the pine
forest and coast take about 40% of the
map rest is a classic tundra map and
mini caves and part of a frozen lake
next up it says five new monsters new
poison yaku Raptors am trio's tigress
and a new arctic fox monster with Oda
Garen skeleton and invasion monster very
powerful like the devil Joe tear and
tsukushi holiday or a more difficult new
moveset just like lune astra and the
release date will be here on August
September this expansion starts the
discovery of an unknown monster the Fox
partic monster arriving the choral
Highlands first special assignment is to
repel the Fox then it will escape to the
north following her will lead the player
to the tundra and then the last two
assignments are to kill a fox in a
tempered rusted Guiche oliday aura and
then lastly to end it says on here PC
releases in early October still no
footage shown of it and a new trailer
and info on the generation ultimate
during the Nintendo presentation and
Nibiru faruk ooh amiibo announced once
again probably butchered that name
already but it does sound cool
regardless let me know what you guys
think in the comments below and I'm
obviously a Monster Hunter noob so I do
not know if any of these monsters have
previously been in the game it seems
like it just by the fact that this guy
is just naming off monsters left and
right like tigress and Zam trios and Al
a tree on or all that type of stuff so
I'm assuming these are monsters from
past games I'll try to probably put
images on screen just in case nobody
knows what those monsters look like if I
find them on Google or something like
that and then aswell distempered rusted
couche oliday aura which seems really
cool I'm assuming the rust didn't
version mean it's probably gonna have a
type of brown coat as opposed to some
type of silver or grey what couche
oliday are currently has what I'm really
interested to see this new ice arctic
fox which with the ODA Geron type
skeleton it looks really cool it sounds
nice
I wonder how this is going to play out
maybe it's going to have a similar move
set to Oda girl but the fast paced moves
and the quick attacks maybe it will also
do bleed as well and it's also pretty
cool that we're going to be getting the
release date of these monsters
predictably it's about going to be
August to September that's going to be
the yaku Raptors am trio's tigress this
Odegard skeleton monster looking thing
with the arctic fox and the rusted
couche oliday aura with this al tree on
probably coming in the later of June
just to put that bridge of the monthly
monsters coming out which seems really
cool regardless yeah as I said before
let me know what you guys think in the
comments below I think this is gonna be
really cool seems like a lot of old
monsters are coming into the monster on
a world series so a lot of old monsters
are gonna have new imbued graphics
textures is gonna look amazing kind of
problem maybe have similar move sets
maybe new move sets I have no idea if
either way these are going to be cool
and there's gonna be really awesome to
fight but to end off the video just as
another reminder this is clearly 100%
speculation this is no hard proof facts
this could possibly come true this could
not like I said this is all speculation
based off of a
leak or rumor unfortunate about the e3
conference so like I said take all this
with a grain of salt because this may or
may not come true but with that like the
V if you do enjoy guys subscribe if
you're new I'll cover the leaks in these
rumors of anything that comes up in
Monster Hunter World whenever that stuff
happens to release ever as well as news
and I cover the solo guides for Monster
Hunter World as well especially the
higher up monsters that I will
definitely be doing solo guys on these
monsters coming up if that like I said
this is true I also covered tips and
tricks and guides and stuff like that to
keep everybody up to date on what to do
and how to be a better Monster Hunter
role player I mean that guys hope we
have a great rest your day thanks for
watching the video hopefully you enjoyed
that and with that thank you for
watching the video peace out